after two long years finally the
decision on Stargate looks like it's
been made
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now on the side Channel I did a video
um just Saturday gone about this rumor
and in that video I said this is almost
certainly not true
that this is so unlikely I just I just
don't believe it
but between that video being recorded
and it going live on the Saturday
morning I got another message from one
of my sources repeating the same rumor
then a third
so I contacted somebody I know really
well and asked them to ask around for me
he came back to me 12 hours later with
the message yes
the rumor looks like it's true but what
am I talking about now if you saw the
live video on Sunday you'll know exactly
what I'm talking about but in this video
I'm going to try to be very specific and
very clear I want no confusion because I
have I have had a few questions to
answer around and what about this what
about that so I'm going to try to be
really as clear as I can be
um I'm going to tell you that this is
very exciting news
but it's not the whole story and it's
not the full green light that some
people are really waiting for so what is
the room okay so Jennifer sulky is the
head of MGM studio and Amazon Studios
March 1st they hired ahead of movies for
Amazon and MGM that lady is Courtney
Valentini now we have been waiting for
that for a long time I've talked about
that in a million different videos that
loads and loads of projects were
basically on hold because they didn't
have a chief executive in charge of
movies now why would they wait basically
take two years to get a movie from
development to the actual screen that's
a long time and if you have an executive
that isn't really passionate about a
project in charge during that period it
can make things very difficult so they
do not want to announce any major
projects until that manager was in place
now that executive is in place they can
get started and Jennifer sulky are
Monday just gone did send a directive to
um Miss Valentini that directive
basically covered several projects it
was talking about Legally Blonde it
talked about James Bond it talked about
um a Exorcist reboot and a couple of
other things that directive seemed to be
okay these projects need to be back on
track now I want this done by this time
let's crack on but what did the
directive say about Stargate well
according to my sources it said that by
the end of this year preferably by
Autumn Time end of summer autumn but by
the end of this year we expect filming
to have started we would like a
cinematic release by the end of 2024
early 2025
so just to reiterate a cinematic release
of from the Stargate franchise
so the first thing I asked will this be
within Canon now we don't know for sure
because we don't know what Claudia
Valentini is going to do in lots of ways
we are looking at a clean slate for this
project now we have had loads of
development done building up to this
point we've had loads of conversations
we have had conversations with penguin
and Parker and penguin and Parker look
like they have started to do some of the
development work or at least putting
some IDs together for what they would
like to do with the Stargate franchise
I am told that it is penguin in a Parker
that have spoken very unofficially two
two or three actors including Robert
Carlisle David blue who demand tapping
potentially
um and um Michael Shanks also it is
through penguin and Parker that Miles
Teller has been very again unofficially
approached about potentially leading the
Stargate franchise all of these actors
though they've been approached again
it's very unofficial it's a if we were
to do this would you like to now penguin
and Parker have been doing that because
they've been trying to figure out where
they want to take the Stargate franchise
and knowing What actors would
potentially be willing to appear in that
franchise is really important for them
to actually do the work they cannot do a
series based around Amanda Tapping
Samantha Carter if Amanda Tapping turns
around and says I'm not doing it so they
have to send out some of these feelers
even well before anything is official
just to get an idea on who might be
willing to return
now I get to hear about this news
because I have certain contacts in and
around agencies that are big in
Hollywood but that doesn't mean that
these actors will ever actually appear
in any franchise it just means exactly
what I've said that they've been sounded
out about whether they would like to
return and most are told that this will
be an sg1 Revival now again that doesn't
necessarily mean all of the actors
unless you are going to return it means
that the movies and the franchise etc
etc will potentially be called sg1 and
will be based around the sg1 team going
through Gates doing like that the actors
that they've approached though are seem
to be from across the board
now there's definitely been focusing on
SGU but also some sg1 characters I would
also love to see some Stargate Atlantis
characters return if Joe Flanagan
doesn't come back to Stargate I don't
know what we're doing
so it does seem that the plan or the
idea at the moment the Penguin and the
Parker have is to cherry pick their
favorite actors from across all three
series and put them into a new series
based roughly around the formula of sg1
so does that mean we're about to get a
green light for a Stargate movie no
probably not
but it will be reasonably soon what this
does mean is that they've made the
decision then they're going to go with a
movie now I know that penguin and Parker
has been doing a lot of the preliminary
work on what they would like to do with
Stargate they have been trying to figure
out where they're going to start how
they're going to develop what the end
game is and what sort of and format it
would be but Amazon hadn't decided
whether it was going to be a movie or a
series and that was a big problem for
penguin in a park and one of the reasons
why Mark Fergus actually is refusing at
the moment to continue negotiations now
there were several negotiations between
Mark Fergus from penguin and Parker and
Amazon at Christmas but they kind of
broke down
um partly because they ran out of time
before the Christmas holidays partly
because there were some disagreements on
budget but also partly because Mark
Fergus just basically said look am I
doing a film or a series am I doing both
what am I doing and Amazon hadn't
decided now they have so again this is
partly because of that they need to get
all their ducks in a row they need to
actually make that first decision what
are we doing now Courtney Valentino has
to go away and figure out a few more
details about what are they doing we
need a production company we need maybe
a couple of actors to have signed up
they need something that when they
announce it it's more than just oh we're
doing Stargate Amazon don't work like
that they don't announce anything until
one they actually have to and two
they've actually got something to say so
at what point will this be green lip
it'll be greenlit when a budget is
agreed when an actor is agreed when a
production companies are all agreed all
the contracts are signed and when Amazon
have absolutely no other choice but do
it that's when this will get green lit
and that's when they still get announced
and then the chances are filming will
start within a couple of months of that
point so I'm not going to be getting
worried until I haven't heard anything
until June or July then I would expect
to hear something but guys this is the
decision we've been waiting for this is
the decision penguin and a Parker I've
been waiting for there's still a long
way to go and I know how frustrating
this is but we've had delays upon delays
because they're doing a movie rather
than a series in lots of ways I just
wish they would do a series please go
back and watch our live video from
Sunday I think we would all agree we'd
probably prefer a series we're probably
for it safer and it's probably easier
but
they have all of this money from Amazon
to make so many cinematic releases a
year and Jennifer sulky has obviously
decided that some of that money should
be allocated to Stargate it's very much
a manager's decision but at least it's
the start of something it's the decision
we've been waiting on and it's been made
so we can now buckle up and we can start
looking forward to the future this is
the end of the beginning and the start
of it can exciting new Stargate
franchise future guys get to the
comments go tell me exactly what you
think did you watch the live show we
bounce this idea around a lot what sort
of movie would you like to see what sort
of franchise would you like to see that
would hopefully come after that movie do
you really think a movie is a good idea
or would you prefer a television series
get into the comments tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos like this also please go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you can actually see most of our
videos first and for a small fee you can
watch them before everybody else on
YouTube and without the adverts
please as always stay safe and start
looking forward to a Stargate future
I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you